for this to be a federal election law
violation what has to happen is the
payment had to be made because it was
done with personal funds not like John
Edwards or Hillary Clinton's campaign
issue this was done with personal funds
for it to be a violation of federal
campaign law it had to be done
irrespective the payment would have had
been made irrespective of the campaign
if the payment was made irrespective of
the campaign there's no FEC violation I
am focused laser focused on the in the
case like you just said the legal case I
am not his PR consultant I'm not a
social media consultant and when I took
this case on to represent the president
I knew who the president was he's
someone who was vocal he speaks his mind
sometimes there's no filter it's direct
but that's him that's his methodology
and his style and it got him into the
White House so it's not for me to tell
him how to act of course he's going to
comply with the judge's rulings and the
law and he has by the way that's why the
judge didn't come close to it and given
the gag order yesterday or even
admonishing him but I understand what
you're saying but there's no issue here
yesterday was actually an incredibly
peaceful day insane but peaceful and
that that was next to the Secret Service
NYPD uh Dennis courts Court officers
Union they were amazing so it was really
um for a day that was insane it was
pretty smooth do you feel feel that you
can get a fair jury in Manhattan
I feel that we're not going to get to a
jury Savannah after seeing that
indictment and knowing what the law is
regarding federal election campaigns I
don't think we're getting close to
address I think this case is going to
fall on its merits on legal challenges
well before we get to a jury after we
get to a jury I think any person whether
they're on the right or politically
opposed to Donald Trump or in favor of
him is going to see this for what it is
it's weaponization of the legal system
it's it's something that this country
never did before and hopefully we'll
never do again